en el vídeo anterior tomamos nuestra
primer visión de lo que es la definición
del límite con épsilon y deltas y lo que
esencialmente nos dice es que si pides
que el límite cuando x aproxima hace de
fx es igual a l entonces lo que dicha
definición significa es que si alguien
te da a cualquier épsilon positivo es
esencialmente cuán cerca queremos que
esté f x dl y que también podemos
siempre encontrar un delta que también
va a ser mayor que 0 de tal manera que
ésta va a estar acortando la distancia
que hay entre x y c entonces f x va a
estar también dentro del intervalo que
forma
épsilon de delta y si nosotros podemos
encontrar dicha delta para cualquier
épsilon entonces podemos afirmar que
este límite en efecto el límite de fx
cuando x aproxima a c existe y quizás te
aparezca ahorita un tanto abstracto así
lo que yo quiero hacer es dar un ejemplo
para que veamos cómo funciona esto
entonces tenemos aquí que f
está definida como que es igual a 2x
para cuando x es distinto de 5 y x para
cuando x es igual a 5 y entonces yo la
gráfica por acá esta recta de aquí
representa la recta de 2x que no está
definida cuando x es igual a 5 y para
ese caso tenemos que x es igual a 5 y es
el punto que se encuentra aquí y
entonces ahora si yo te pregunto cuál es
el límite de fx es bonito e intuitivo
verlo para cuando x es igual a 5 pero
quizás no luzca tan sencillo para cuando
hablamos de 2x y tenemos que ver cómo
está representando el valor cuando x es
igual a 5 pues luce como si tuviéramos
10 no sería 2 x 5 y tal vez se luzca
bastante intuitivo hacer la prueba que
del límite de fx cuando x tiende a 5
realmente es igual a 10 pero viéndolo de
otra forma podremos probarlo con la
definición que tenemos decisión del tas
para que quede esto todavía más claro y
la forma en que normalmente la mayoría
de estas pruebas se realizan
es que nosotros vamos a definir de ésta
de forma abstracta y luego esencialmente
tratamos de llegar a delta dado un
cierto épsilon siempre tiende a
convertirse en delta o de otra forma
nosotros trataremos de describir delta
como una función de épsilon pero para no
confundirme mucho o confundirte mucho
vamos a poner que delta va a estar dada
aquí le voy a escribir no va a volver a
repetir efe entonces le vamos a llamar
que está dada por una función de épsilon
pero está definida para cualquier
épsilon positivo así que si tú me das
cualquier épsilon yo tendré que
realmente poner el problema en función
de dicho épsilon y más adelante dar el
cierto delta entonces dudas cualquier
épsilon y siempre siempre se va a
obtener un delta entonces cuando esto es
cierto tenemos en efecto que está la
distancia o el rango que queda entre
delta y sé que tenemos por acá y
entonces sucede que la distancia de fx
con el límite queda acotada con épsilon
y entonces el límite definitivamente
existe así que tratamos de realizar
una vez entonces como tú podrás ver aquí
se es igual a 5 y lo que yo ya hice es
abrir nuestro rango aquí tenemos 5 +
delta y 5 menos delta y ahora esto que
voy a subrayar aquí son las equis que
podemos tomar dentro de dicho intervalo
pero excepto 5 pues recordemos que ahí
no está definido y entonces estas serán
todas las equis que satisfacen dicha
desigualdad entonces vamos a tener que
la distancia de x menos 5 será menor que
delta ahora bien lo que vamos a realizar
es que la forma típica en como estas
pruebas se hacen es que vamos a tratar
de manipular esta desigualdad pues este
lado de la desigualdad que comience a
lucir en algo como esto este lado que
luzca como algo de esta forma y al hacer
esto de nuestro lado derecho de la
desigualdad va a estarse expresando en
términos de delta y luego podremos
esencialmente decir que como está dado
en términos de delta y del otro lado de
esta ecuación está dado en términos de
épsilon entonces podremos llegar a
alguna conjetura común y quizás ahorita
lo veas
no pues no tiene tanto sentido pero
déjame hacerlo o realizarlo y entonces
si lo que queremos es que x lo que
queremos es que x menos cinco luzca como
este este lado de nuestra ecuación de fx
menos el límite cuando x es distinto de
5 entonces tendremos lo siguiente y
entonces tenemos que fx es igual a 2x
para cuando x es distinto de 5 y si
queremos que esto luzca igual que la
función entonces simplemente
multiplicamos dos veces la desigualdad
por ambos lados y vamos a tener que es
dos veces por el valor absoluto de algo
y es lo mismo que si tenemos lo escribir
por acá 2 por el valor absoluto de a es
igual que tener 2 veces el valor
absoluto de a entonces voy a desarrollar
y tendríamos lo siguiente tendríamos el
valor absoluto de 2x menos 10 menor
todo esto menor que 2 de esta y te
repito que esto es para cuando x es
distinto de 5 y entonces literalmente
este es nuestro límite ahora aquí
finalmente tenemos algo parecido a lo
que queríamos de en cuanto a fx
es el límite pues nuestro lado izquierdo
ya corresponde pero ahora de este lado
derecho hay que ver cómo lo definimos
pero antes déjame aquí subrayar te lo
que fx viene siendo que es 2x y el
límite es 10 y entonces ahora sí vamos a
poner a delta en función de épsilon
tenemos que esta desigualdad tiene aquí
a épsilon entonces épsilon va a ser
igual a 2 delta pues simplemente
fijándonos en las desigualdades vemos
que corresponde a lo mismo del lado
izquierdo e igualamos el extremo derecho
de cada desigualdad
entonces si épsilon es igual a 2 delta y
despejamos de esta vamos a hacer vamos a
sería ponerlo lo voy a poner de otro
color vamos a hacer que delta está en
función de épsilon 2 delta es igual a
épsilon entonces despejó delta y delta
va a ser igual a épsilon medios y ahora
observando tenemos que este enunciado de
aquí se convierte en el valor absoluto
bueno vamos a poner primero en lo que
convertimos a delta en términos de
épsilon entonces tenemos que delta es
igual a épsilon medios
y entonces este enunciado de aquí es que
la distancia de fx menos l es menor
dijimos que 2 delta pero 2 de eta ahora
sustituimos lo que representa del tanto
que tenemos que es 2 por épsilon medios
y nos queda que es menor que epsilon y
finalmente aquí tenemos la llave de todo
ahora si cualquier épsilon positivo que
te den simplemente nosotros lo que
tenemos que hacer es que ya tenemos que
para esta función delta es igual a
épsilon medios luego cualquier x dentro
del rango que tenemos van a corresponder
algún fx y éste va a estar dentro de
nuestro límite así que si alguien te
dice que épsilon y recuerda que puede
ser para cualquier persona mayor que 0
podrías ver cómo juega si te dijeran que
épsilon es igual a punto 5 entonces
nuestro límite sabemos que es 10 y aquí
tendríamos que este límite de acá sería
10.5 y por acá abajo tendríamos que
sería 9.5 y ahora con la deducción de
delta de la que hicimos sabemos que
delta es igual a epsilon medios entonces
es punto 5 sobre 2 y esto
la punto 25 entonces nos va a dar un
rango entre 4.75 un rango entre 4.75 y
5.25 donde por supuesto estas x de este
rango que en algún f x que no va a ser
igual a 5 entonces podemos ver como f x
va a caer entre 10.5 y 9.5 entonces es
tan simple como que me den cualquier
épsilon cualquier número mayor que 0 y
utilicemos esta deducción de delta para
obtenerla y ya luego delta nos define
todo este camino que hicimos por aquí y
lo atravesamos para llegar a una
desigualdad como esta donde tenemos que
la distancia entre x menos 5 es menor
que delta y donde delta está definida
por cualquier explotado y este va a ser
el camino que se sigue como fx define
nuestro límite